in this video we're going to go through
two problems involving linear speed and
angular speed let's do the first problem
together and see if you can try the
second one on your own and let's go
through this so the first one it talks
about a wheel of diameter 12 inches
rotates at 10 revolutions per minute we
want to find the linear speed in miles
per hour and the angular speed in
radians per minute so first off what
exactly is linear speed so we have this
wheel that's turning like this right but
imagine a point on that wheel if it was
to go not in a circle but like in a
straight line what would be the distance
that it travels per unit time okay so in
this case we're figuring out how many
miles would it go
in one hour so what we can do is we can
think about this as a unit conversion
problem we're going to start off with
the 10 revolutions per minute and when
you see the word per you're thinking
divided by so 10 revolutions divided by
one minute so 10 rows per minute and
we're trying to convert this into miles
per hour now the key is is that one
revolution once around that Circle
that's the circumference right and we
know that the circumference is pi times
the diameter or 2 pi times the radius so
in this case since we have the diameter
let's do pi times 12 inches
per one revolution so that's how far
you're traveling one revolution notice
the Revolutions in the numerator and
denominator they cancel and we have
inches per minute we want miles per hour
so let's go ahead and continue to
convert this we'll say there's 12 inches
for every one foot so you can see the
inches cancel numerator and denominator
and we know there's
5280 feet for every one mile so now you
can see the feet are canceling and we
have miles per minute we want miles per
hour so we know that there are 60
minutes
for every one hour now the minutes in
the numerator cancel with the minutes in
the denominator and we have miles per
hour so all we're going to do is we're
going to multiply all these numerators
together all these denominators together
and then we're going to divide so let's
go to the calculator and do that so that
comes out to 10 times 12
times pi you can use 3.14 I'm using the
pi key times 60 all divided by in
parentheses 12 times 5280.
so that comes out to approximately
0.35 actually let's do 0.357
miles per hour
now let's say we want to do the angular
speed so that's the second part of the
equation I would go back to the 10
revolutions per minute so we'll say 10
revolutions per one minute
but we know that for every one
revolution see it turns once around
that's 360 degrees or that's the same as
2 pi radians so you probably know that
from your unit circle so 2 pi radians
per one rev notice the revolutions
cancel numerator and denominator and
we're left with radians
per minute and that's what we want so if
we go ahead and multiply horizontally
here we get 20 Pi radians
per minute and you got it let's take a
look at another example
okay see if you can challenge yourself
and do the second problem on your own
we've got a 29 inch bicycle tire and
when they say 29 inches that means the
diameter of the tire is 29 inches it
makes 25 Revolutions in one minute
what's the linear speed in feet per
minute and the angular speed in radians
per minute so how would you go ahead and
do that one well if I was going to do it
I would start off with the 25
Revolutions in one minute so 25
Revolutions in one minute
and we know that for every one
revolution once around that when the
tire makes one complete turn it's going
to travel
29 Pi inches because remember pi times
diameter is the circumference that's the
distance once around that bicycle tire
but notice now where the revolutions are
cancellating numerator and denominator
we're left with inches per minute we
want feet per minute so we're going to
take it one step further for every 12
inches that's one foot so you can see
the inches are canceling numerator and
denominator and we're left with the
units feet per minute which is what we
want now sometimes your teacher will say
you know leave this as an exact answer
and if that's the case you would want to
leave this pie in here so we're just
going to multiply 25 times 29
times 1. so let's go ahead and do that
real quick on the calculator let's see
so 25 times 29 FK times 1 is
725 pi
1 times 1 times 12
it comes out to 12 and this is in
feet per minute
okay but now notice you can reduce this
down a little bit let's see does that
reduce down let's see nine five no it
doesn't look like it reduces so this
would be an exact answer
725 pi over 12 feet per minute but if we
want to get an approximation I'm going
to go ahead and use the pi key
it's approximately
189.8
feet
per minute now let's go ahead and do the
angular speed so the angular speed again
I like to go back to the revolutions per
minute the 25 revolutions per one minute
and we know our conversion factor for
every one revolution once around that
Circle it's traveling or the angle that
it's traveling through is 360 degrees or
you could say 2 pi radians okay so this
way the revolutions cancel numerator and
denominator and we're left with a
radians per minute which is what we want
and so if I multiply it horizontally
across here we get 25 times 2 is 50 pi
divided by one so this is 50 Pi radians
radians per
minute and that's your angular speed the
angle that it turns through in one
minute so great job if you're able to
get that one if you want to see another
video that I did with some more examples
linear speed and angular speed I'll put
a video right there on the screen go
ahead and click on that video follow me
over and we'll get some more practice
I'll see you there